se cumplen 40 años de la guerra entre
argentina y reino unido por las malvinas
argentinas aún reclama sus derechos
sobre los más de 12 mil kilómetros de
territorio que conforman el archipiélago
cuando una política de estado una
posición del estado argentino ante el
tema que es justamente el reclamo de
soberanía eso no es algo que ningún
gobierno haya claudicado
sino bloqueada lo que cambió es la forma
de
aproximarse al de la guerra inició el 2
de abril y duró tan sólo 74 días
participaron 23 mil combatientes
argentinos que carecían de suministros
básicos frente a los 26.000 del reino
unido- bien equipados se desplegaron 216
aviones y 38 buques argentinos contra
117 aviones y 111 buques del reino unido
los enfrentamientos dejaron 649 muertos
argentinos y 255 del reino unido la
guerra dejó decenas de denuncias de
torturas y humillaciones ejecutadas en
contra de los soldados argentinos por
parte de mandos superiores así como el
olvido del estado y la población a los
soldados se les hizo más difícil porque
la sociedad éste los negaba la mayoría
no conseguía trabajo y eso fue lo
difícil después de volver a encontrarte
con que la sociedad te rechazaba o te
ignoraba reino unido no volvió a acceder
a negociaciones sobre la soberanía de
las islas